what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Avengers Beyond I.E the
return of the proper beyonders to the
Marvel Universe now what this does is
this picks up with the Avengers fighting
the black order and for the most part
everybody here is recognizable to you if
for no other reason than infinity War
The Only Exception would be Black Swan
and unless you've read Marvel Comics you
don't know who she is black Swan's part
of the black order she has been for
quite some time she's basically Valeria
Richards the daughter of Reed Richards
from an alternate reality she's really
powerful but under normal circumstances
I wouldn't care about the Avengers
fighting the black order I'm telling you
about this so you understand what
happens next because the Avengers are
about to get wrecked and not even by a
little bit right not even buying a
little bit so the funny thing about the
black order is they're easily of an
Avengers level threat right they go
toe-to-toe with these guys and it really
is just a knock down drag out fight and
for the most part The Avengers are able
to hold their own now one of the things
to understand that's been going on here
and this is something that we talked
about in the last video all of this is
based around the concept of the lost one
in Marvel Comics which is to say a newly
introduced being who's responsible for
the beyonders getting their power he's
this guy that's just astronomically
powerful I mean being able to alter
reality unlike a multiversal scale the
beyonders rebelled against him stole his
power and then locked him away he
ultimately escaped and he's been
traveling through the universe and even
the Multiverse trying to find the
beyonders and killed him everywhere he
can the black order being here is a
result of them being summoned and kind
of brought in by the lost one himself
but the kicker behind all this is
there's a great big huge kind of barrier
that surrounds the Earth that was really
created with the assistance of the
beyonder to keep the lost one out it's
not gonna work because while the
Avengers were able to overcome the black
order at the end of the day Captain
America calls out to the beyonder
because remember the beyonder originally
appeared warned the Avengers of the lost
one and then took off but Captain
America knows the beyonder can hear him
because the beyonder is kind of watching
everything that's going on even if you
can't physically see him but the thing
about this is The Shield suddenly goes
down and then the lost one shows up now
leaving out the fact that this guy looks
like Super Shredder this dude is a Haas
an absolute Hoss here's the funny thing
about this man it's like this amazing
moment because as The Avengers are
standing there right Captain America
Captain righteous is like you're not
taking one step further this dude
doesn't say a word and takes one step
further Iron Man Blossom with this
energy blast all the Avengers jump in
this guy's like man son you better come
strong this guy punches Thor sends him
flying levels Captain Marvel in one shot
takes out Captain America in one hit
just like knocks this guy to the ground
Thor jumps back in with another hit gets
blasted into the ceiling done like it's
one of those crazy moments it's just
it's amazing to see this happen so what
this guy does is he basically walks up
to water four crystals takes them and
then basically proceeds to LEAP Now The
Avengers try to rally themselves and try
to go back in on the assault only for
them to realize this Shield's back up
again and that's when it Dawns on
Captain America when the beyonders
showed up here and the beyonder said I
will help you guys basically build a
shield that will keep out the lost one
you can Marshal your forces you can
bring together whatever Powers you need
to in order to defeat this guy I mean
good luck right because as the beyonders
we killed all the cosmic entities
including the Living Tribunal this guy
is more powerful than us so hey man uh I
don't know what to tell you right like
what he realizes is when the shield goes
back up it was never about to be under
helping them it was about the beyonder
setting a trap it was the beyonder
lowering the shield so the last one
would come in collect the four crystals
and then in turn the shield would go
back up and keep him trapped on Earth
with nowhere to go and so following this
the beyonder Alters reality Within Earth
and then creates like a whole nother set
of Avengers which initially fight
against the main Avengers themselves
it's a little funny it's kind of
interesting it's not overly significant
but then the group basically turns its
sights on the lost one and of course
once the fight breaks out again they all
get crushed again right you think they
would have learned their lesson the
first time but then like the beyonder
himself shows up and initially he goes
to challenge the lost one right he says
like greetings my fearsome friend I am
Yonder The bootleg beyonder what manner
of being might you be right because it's
like the bootleg Avengers this guy just
snatches them up right and it's just
like no we're not doing this right this
this game's over and once the fight's
back on again of course the Avengers
taken out quite readily I mean they're
just they're demolished and so the funny
thing here is that this guy takes off
his helmet he realizes the main beyonder
himself is still out there the bootleg
beyonder was just like a facsimile and
this guy flies out to the very edge of
the barrier he can't pass it but he
flies out to the very edge of the
barrier and then starts talking to the
beyonder and just says like you have my
power I want it back now one thing to
remember here is that once the lost one
was on the Move what the beyonder told
us is that all the other beyonders
across existence were just fleeing for
their lives that's literally the best
they could do that was the best they
could hope for was to just run and hope
they didn't get caught because the
instant this guy got a portion of his
power back it was more than enough to
take out any one particular beyonder and
so tracking them down individually they
never had a chance the funny thing here
is the entirety of this barrier and the
entire basis behind how it exists comes
by way of all the beyonders appearing
now a little bit of explanation here we
probably should have done this earlier
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with the beyonders again they're
ridiculously overpowered they come from
the Beyond verse there are different
variations of their origin and Marvel
Comics you can just kind of go with
whatever origin you want to but again
like we mentioned earlier in Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers they
killed all the Cosmic entities one
beyonder in a single Universe was
powerful enough to wipe out every Cosmic
entity Galactus The celestials Eternity
Infinity the whole nine yards three
beyonders were powerful enough to
destroy the Living Tribunal the living
embodiment of the Multiverse and what's
supposed to be the second most powerful
being in existence after the one above
all In This Moment here we've got four
not only that The Lost Ones more
powerful than them just to give you guys
perspective here now the nature behind
the crystals is that they are in fact
beyonders themselves and that's what the
main beyonder did is he basically used
the crystals or used beyonders condensed
them down to an almost crystalline form
and then basically have them operating
as a kind of source of power for the
nature of the shield imprisoning The
Lost One using the power of the
beyonders themselves now where the other
beyonders show up here and they really
kind of chastise him for his actions the
response of the lost one is like I'm
going to kill every single one of you
you are all going to die and he can do
it too well at least if you never get
past the shield and in fact what the
beyonders say is exactly that your
Shield is imperfect Beyond her it's only
a matter of time before someone with
enough power manages to break through it
this guy might not necessarily be able
to do it but somebody will and when that
happens all hell's gonna break loose
right it's going to be an absolute
Calamity and so following that they
basically tell him what you've done here
until such a time that someone's able to
break through this Shield you've
effectively saved our people from
complete and total Annihilation but we
cannot ignore the fact that you have
attacked one of your own or at least
your own people themselves you attack
them you can find them to a state of
living death and they will stay here on
Earth forever operating as a source of
power for a barrier to try to keep this
guy trapped so you beyonder are banished
from your kind you are no longer welcome
to us as the beyonders they strip him of
his power literally take away
every ounce of power that this guy has
they say you will be confined back to a
human form and you will be sent back to
Earth they cast him down so this guy
goes crashing down to the surface and
the beyonder is now human now of course
the question has to be asked what in the
world happens next we don't know because
the comic's not out yet but if you guys
want to get caught up make sure you
click the link to this video which will
give you the first video that we did
that'll fill in all the gaps and any
questions that you might have thank you
all for watching and I will catch you
all later peace